kayla is with us Kayla is in California
how are you Kayla
I'm good how are you good Merry
Christmas not going to help Merry
Christmas
so I will be 26 in a few days
my boyfriend is 31 and we are avid
spenders and also I'm about 27,000 and
debt and he's about 40,000 in debt
how do I get him motivated I'm a new
listener of yours and every free minute
of my last two weeks has gone to you so
I'm very motivated and I've done making
minimum payments here and there and
scrounging for payment money I've put
together my debt snowball listening to
you and watching videos and other people
how do I get him on the same page as me
cuz he's okay with just making payment
and I'm not well you were three weeks
ago I was three weeks ago and now so
what what change between now and then
new information that made you the new
information was inserted into your brain
that made you believe yes I've looked at
all my statements I've seen how much
extra money I'm paying by putting off
paying in bigger chunks and getting rid
of this but you've watched youtube
videos of other people doing it you've
heard me teach the debt snowball none of
which you knew about a month and a half
or two months ago and that new
information that those other people that
are doing this and this is how you do it
and these are the steps made you believe
that's called hope and you had that
angry at myself yes yeah you had but you
have you can you see that it can be done
and so you smack yourself in the
forehead and go I got to do this right
and so he doesn't have that same set of
information and so they don't the only
difference in you and him is your month
and a half or two months ahead of him on
information gathering so he needs the
same information when he gets the same
information
if he doesn't join you on this crusade
then we've got other issues he's either
lazy
he's hopeless he can't he can't you know
because hope was awakened inside of you
when other people did it and I showed
you a clear path agreed correct
and if hope isn't awakened inside of him
when I do the same thing for him then
we've got other issues
well his income is double what mine is
so he can afford all of his monthly
payment no exam he's like okay it's
absolutely absurd he has a great income
and it's stupid that he's in debt yeah
nothing okay about it at all I mean
between the two of us we bring in like
200 grand a year and I feel like not
scrounging but we're almost there
because we're vendors and so well you're
out of control you're spending like
you're in Congress yeah you just out of
control and say you woke up and kind of
had the aha moment went whoa
you know dr. Phil moment how's this
working for you you know it's not and so
I have to change some stupid stuff
because if I keep doing what I've been
doing I'm gonna keep getting what I've
been getting right and these this is the
aha moment though the revelation that
the epiphany that you have had and it's
unfair to expect him to have that drop
out of the sky into his brain the reason
you had that was you have information
that he doesn't have so you've got to
you know turn him on to YouTube I'll
send you a copy of the Total Money
Makeover book y'all read it together
start talking about it because couples
that are not on the same page with money
very seldom get married or stay married
mm-hmm that's what I want to avoid yeah
so it's very important that you get on
the same page but again I can't say
anything negative about him he just
doesn't know what you know so of course
he's not motivated he's the same guy who
was two months before three months
before and and the same as you are three
months ago mm-hmm yeah you were no
better three months ago and so you know
you you've got new information and
you're smiling and you're pumped and
you're like going for it and you got a
goal and you believe it can happen and
you know all these awesome things are
happening now in your brain I'm so proud
of it it's very cool and I think you can
my point is I think you can turn him on
to this he's just you just got to you
know not expect him
to magically get this just because
you're excited he needs to see needs
together and see the same information
that you have and then if he doesn't
catch on and then we got other issues
then we got other issues so hey good
question hold on I'll have Kelly pick up
for you and she'll send you a copy of
the Total Money Makeover book as my
Christmas gift to him and then you guys
read that through together pop on some
of those debt-free screams there's
hundreds and hundreds of them on the
YouTube channel and you know jump in the
Financial Peace University even if you
want is pre marriage counseling or
something that kind of thing folks
people don't engage in transformational
things in their lives unless they think
they're going to work why would you go
to the gym and sweat and call that fun
you only do it because you want muscles
you want to have better aerobic
efficiency of your heart you want to be
in better shape
reason you do it the Bible says no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but he lists of righteousness so why
would I engage in painful things unless
they and unless I believe they were
going to bring me a better future and
that's the normal human activity that's
how we all think that's a good thing